[Applaus]
[Musik]
luxemburg ist eines der wenigen länder
dieser welt in dem sich der
premierminister öffentlich zu seiner
homosexualität bekannt hat ihr sprechen
von einer der tolerantesten und auf
geschlossenen gesellschaften der welt
bei einer bevölkerung von rund 500.000
einwohner haben und 40 prozent von ihnen
einen migrationshintergrund
[Musik]
dabei ist luxemburg sowohl das kleinste
land der europäischen union als auch
gleichzeitig das land mit dem größten
anteil an einwanderer
nichtsdestotrotz was luxemburg berühmt
macht kann in einem einzigen wort
zusammengefasst werden geld ja meine
lieben freunde soll politik das
großherzogtum luxemburg sondern zu den
top drei der reichsten länder der welt
der mindestlohn liegt hier bei 2000 euro
pro monat und das ist der mindestlohn
denn normalerweise verdient man hier
über 5000 euro im monat
[Musik]
zum besseren verständnis die luxemburger
haben einen bip pro kopf das doppelt so
groß ist wie das der australier oder der
den ok ok aber wartet mal eine sekunde
denn es gibt einen kleinen haken in
diesem vergleich fast die hälfte der
menschen die in luxemburg arbeiten lebt
außerhalb luxemburgs täglich pendeln
rund 160.000 menschen nach luxemburg und
kehren dann nach deutschland frankreich
oder belgien zurück nach hause mit
anderen worten sich auf den wohlstand im
land luxemburg leben dort aber nicht aus
diesem grund erhalten wir eine so enorm
hohe zahl werden wir luxemburgs bip auf
die dort lebende bevölkerung aufteilen
aber selbst wenn man die statistischen
abweichungen einkalkuliert kann niemand
leugnen dass luxemburg eine art bilanz
der millionäre ist und das erklärt warum
die hauptstadt stadt luxemburg zu den
städten mit der höchsten lebensqualität
gehört
[Musik]
viele von euch würden glauben dass dies
alles dadurch erklärt werden kann dass
luxemburg ein steuerparadies ist die
wahrheit aber ist dass andere länder wie
malta oder zypern auch niedrige steuern
haben aber nicht einmal halb so reich
sind sie luxemburg die große frage ist
die nach also woher kommt diese immense
wohlstand was haben sie in diesem land
getan um eine so hohe lebensqualität
diese zu können heute werden wir diese
frage beantworten aber vorher wollen wir
noch einen blick in die geschichte
werfen
[Musik]
die stahl könige im jahr 1815 wurde das
großherzogtum luxemburg zu einem
unabhängigen land und ich sage
unabhängig in anführungszeichen weil
keiner seiner nachbarn
diese unabhängigkeit wirklich anerkannt
frankreich und preußen versuchten
mehrmals das herzogtum zu erobern
tatsächlich gehörte das territorium
luxemburgs aber eigentlich dem könig der
niederlande wilhelm den dritten
obwohl es eigentlich unabhängig sein
wollte zu dieser zeit war luxemburg weit
davon entfernt ein wohlhabendes land zu
sein
die meisten seiner bürger lebten eher
schlecht als recht von der
landwirtschaft und dem eisenberg bau
damals wanderte jeder fünfte luxemburger
nach amerika aus also 20 prozent der
bevölkerung
dennoch hat es auch seine vorteile
zwischen zwei miteinander
konkurrierenden ländern wie frankreich
und preußen zu reden zu dieser zeit gab
es noch keinen deutschland als
eigenständigen staat
stattdessen gab es viele kleine
verschiedene deutschen kleinstaaten
königreiche und über die in einem
staatenbund dem deutschen bund
vereinbaren
wenn ihr wissen wollt was ein
staatenbund ist klickt auf dieses video
nun all diese deutschen staaten haben
untereinander handel getrieben
dazu schufen sie eine art spezielle
freihandelszone den sogenannten
zollverein und im jahr 1842 wurde auch
luxemburg mitglied dieses zollvereins
von da an ging es mit luxemburg aufwärts
wie ich schon sagte die örtliche
wirtschaft luxemburgs basierte auf zwei
haupt industrie landwirtschaft und
eisenberg bau und denkt dann werden uns
in den zeiten der industriellen
revolution stahl wurde im grunde
genommen für alles benötigt von
maschinen bis hin zum gebäude bau und
luxemburg besaß zufällig sehr große
vorräte an eisen ärzten aber nicht nur
das wir sprechen von einem winzigen land
das strategisch perfekt liegt auf der
grenze zwischen deutschland frankreich
und belgien
mit anderen worten es war der perfekte
standort für eine eisenbahnlinie die das
reisen in alle drei länder
transportieren von
[Musik]
aus dem stand heraus wurde luxemburg
damit zum ausgangspunkt all dieser
handelsrouten und gleichzeitig einer der
größten stahl anbieter der welt
tatsächlich wurden viele dieser new
yorker wolkenkratzer mit balken aus
luxemburg gebaut
daher sind auch die größten
stahlunternehmen luxemburgisch vor allem
das größte von allen astarloa metall
kurz gesagt nur wenigen jahrzehnten
gelangte luxemburg wirtschaftlich auf
eine stufe mit seinen nachbarn
es war allerdings immer noch nicht der
wirtschaftliche ganz der es heute ist es
fehlte noch an einer speziellen zutat
und diese besondere zutat war diese hier
[Musik]
1929 das ist das jahr in dem luxemburg
die gesetzesbegründung von
holding-gesellschaften verabschiedet hat
aber einen moment jetzt fragt ihr euch
vielleicht was ist eigentlich zu einer
holdinggesellschaft nun nehmen wir coca
cola als beispiel coca cola ist
einerseits eine getränkemarke aber auf
der anderen seite gibt es die firma
krone
es handelt sich um einen großen
mischkonzern zudem auch unternehmen die
fantas webs oder coca cola die
getränkemarke gesetzt
[Musik]
ok dieses große konglomerate wird also
als holding-gesellschaft verzeichnet und
den unternehmen die sich darin befinden
werden als tochterunternehmen bezeichnet
diese tochtergesellschaften können sich
in verschiedenen ländern befinden und
stellen die eigentlichen produkte her
die aufgabe der holding gesellschaft
besteht nämlich hauptsächlich darin ihr
eigentum also jene tochtergesellschaften
zu verwalten ok also dieses gesetz von
1929 bot diesen holdings gute steuer
bedingungen an
im wesentlichen zählten sie rund ein
prozent steuern
was waren die 30er jahre
damals gab es noch nicht so viele
unternehmen wie heute denke nur daran
dass coca cola in diesen jahren erst
begann auf andere märkte zu expandieren
aber coca cola aber anderen sich der
riese der ist rothe ist kurz gesagt dank
der günstigen steuersätzen von rowlings
wuchs luxemburg aber nicht viel mehr als
andere länder auf
[Musik]
die siebzigerjahre waren jedes jahrzehnt
in dem amerikanische unternehmen die
europäischen und asiatischen markt
eroberten
denn dort war endlich genügend wohlstand
entstanden und diesen für immer mehr
konsumgüter ausgeben zu können in diesen
jahren gestanden viele große unternehmen
die wir auch heute noch kennen als wohl
den gesellschaften die rund um den
globus gewinne erwirtschaftet und wohin
haben diese global player ihre
hauptsitze verlegt nun da sie wählen
konnten gingen sie an ihre orte welche
die besten steuerbedingungen boten und
luxemburg bot alles was sie wollten und
noch mehr geradezu paradiesische
bedingungen für globale rolex das so
müsst ihr verstehen dass das land
bereits in den 60er und 70er jahren über
einen großen banken sektor verfügt die
besten anwälte buchhalter konomen lebten
dort und waren bereits diesen großen
unternehmen zu helfen um den
größtmöglichen nutzen aus der dortigen
zu ihrer geschäfte äußerste wohl
gesunden gesetzgebung zu ziehen und so
erlebte dieses land zunächst sein
silbernes jahrzehnt
[Musik]
auch wenn dies unglaublich aussieht der
wirtschaft luxemburgs wuchs in weniger
als sechs jahren auf die doppelte größe
im vergleich dazu sind die
wachstumsraten in china oder singapur
ist nur ein witz und ja du hast richtig
gehört
ich sagte das silberne jahrzehnt weil
diese wachstumsraten nichts im vergleich
zu den wahren was danach kam
denkt daran wir sprechen jetzt schon
über die 2000er jahre
die zeiten des internet booms diese
brandneuen konzerne bauten ihre
geschäfte gleiche weltweit und mit
dutzenden von tochtergesellschaften in
jedem land auf und waren nicht nur auf
eine bestimmte region beschränkt da sie
ihre angebote er übers internet überall
anbieten konnten
[Musik]
mit anderen worten die technologie
unternehmen neben luxemburg
also wenn ihr dachte dass ein land das
bereits millionär ist erwachsen könnte
na ja falsch gedacht
[Musik]
erstaunlich nicht wahr ich weiß nicht ob
es euch aufgefallen ist aber in nur fünf
jahren stieg luxemburg bip pro kopf von
50.000 us dollar was bereits viel ist
auch über 100.000 us dollar
wenn man in einem land mit einem pro
kopf bip von über 100.000 us dollar
lebte dann kann man wohl täglich in
champagner baden oder so in der tat ist
der audi a3 das am dritthäufigsten
verkaufte außerdem luxemburg und ja ich
weiß was ihr denkt dass dieses land
seinen wohlstand damit erwirtschaftet
hat unternehmen zu helfen die ihre
steuern nicht zahlen oder nun die
antwort ist natürlich kompletter ist
[Musik]
die tatsache dass ich eine
holding-gesellschaft in luxemburg
befindet bedeutet nicht dass seine
tochtergesellschaften keine steuern an
anderer stelle zahlen so hat amazon zum
beispiel seinen hauptsitz in luxemburg
dennoch ist zum beispiel die deutsche
amazon tochtergesellschaft also das
unternehmen das in diesem land produkte
verkaufen und die logistik verwaltet in
deutschland steuerpflichtig oder
zumindest theoretisch tatsächlich sieht
es noch mal ganz anders aus luxemburg
kommen wir noch mal auf das amazon
beispiel zurück die wir bereits
erwähnten werden aus den gewinnen der
deutschen tochtergesellschaft steuern
hin und deutschland abgeführt richtig
nun aber es passierte denn wenn amazon
hier gar keinen gewinn erzielt stellt
euch vor dass amazon gleich nach ines
steuern bezahlt hat einen großen kredit
aufnimmt
eine großen krediten mit einem extrem
hohen zinssatz so hoch dass das
unternehmen in deutschland verluste
macht tja und wer leitet dieses geld
amazon holding sl luxemburg auf diese
weise machen die tochtergesellschaften
fast keine gewinne auf die eine oder
andere weise schaffen sie es so ihr geld
an die luxemburgische niederlassung zu
transferieren und die wir bereits sagten
in luxemburg ssen die steuern für
unternehmen extrem niedrig
[Musik]
selbstverständlich ist das alles völlig
legal aber während der große finanzkrise
im jahr 2009 erkannte die amerikanische
regierung dass sie mit all diesen großen
übernehmen die nach über sie ziehen sehr
sehr viel geld verloren seitdem
orientieren sich auch andere regierungen
an obamas initiative vergesst nicht
luxemburg ist eines der
gründungsmitglieder der europäischen
union
das bedeutet dass die andere eu kollegen
mit der zeit rechts wurden und bereit
waren großen politischen druck auszuüben
die größte krise des landes kam im jahr
das war zu der zeit als eine gruppe von
buchhaltern eine menge geheimer daten
aus großen unternehmen veröffentlichte
dank der sogenannten luxemburg leaks
konnten wir all die strategien zur
steuerumgehung von tausenden von
unternehmen einsehen was ich euch über
darlehen zwischen verschiedenen
tochtergesellschaften innerhalb einer
holding-gesellschaft erzählt haben jetzt
kommt eine noch weitaus bessere
möglichkeit her
all diese großen unternehmen
beauftragten große beratungsunternehmen
damit diese ihnen bei der buchhaltung
helfen beratungsunternehmen wie
pricewaterhousecoopers mit einem großen
kunden portfolio für in luxemburg
diese akkumulieren so viele kunden wie
möglich um macht zu erlangen um sich
dann zum beispiel mit dem damaligen
ministerpräsidenten und juhnke
zusammenzusetzen und mit diesem eine
ganz spezielles steuerabkommen zu
vereinbaren
juncker im rampenlicht nach luxemburg
steuer enthüllungen die durchgesickerten
dokumente zeigen die von
pricewaterhousecoopers ausgehandelten
steuerregelungen ihr euch vorstellen
könnt verändert die veröffentlichung
dieser luxemburg liegt die spielregeln
im jahr 2017 hat luxemburg in der tat
eine brandneue steuerreform beschlossen
und wahrscheinlich werden sich viele
regelungen um orientieren müssen aber
wartet einen moment denn das bedeutet
nicht dass luxemburg nicht mehr reich
sein wird ganz im gegenteil
aus dieser politischen turbulenzen ist
das land im vergangenen jahr mit einer
wachstumsrate von 4,2 prozent gewachsen
das ist schneller als fast jedes andere
land europas seine in golden jahren
erwirtschaftet enorm spanische hat
luxemburg nämlich in viele andere
branchen investiert selbstverständlich
haben wir den stahl die banken und das
weltall
luxemburgs wette auf die
raumfahrtindustrie zeigt erste anzeichen
von erfolg
ihr habt richtig gehört tatsächlich sind
luxemburg und die vereinigten staaten
die ersten länder die gesetze zur
regelung des bergbaus auf asteoriden
verlassen haben und diese winzigen land
wird voraussichtlich zum silicon valley
der luft und raumfahrtindustrie
dies jedenfalls erklärt einige details
der steuerreform und 2017
selbstverständlich wird die
luxemburgische regierung großunternehmen
nicht mehr so unverhohlen dabei helfen
steuergesetze in anderen ländern massiv
zu umgehen zumindest ist das die
offizielle version
stattdessen haben sich die steuersätze
für kleine unternehmen gesenkt das
bedeutet dass sie die bedingungen für
das entstehen von technologie startups
verbessern
[Musik]
aber darüber werden wir in einem anderen
video sprechen
jetzt lautet die frage an euch glaubt
ihr wir werden eine weitere phase
rasanten wachstums von luxemburgs
wirtschaft erleben soll dieses land zum
weltweit führenden unternehmen in der
luft und raumfahrtindustrie werden bitte
hinterlasst eure antworten im
kommentarbereich und vergesst nicht dass
wir jede woche brandneue videos
veröffentlichen also klickt auf den
button und ihr werdet keinen beitrag
verpassen
wenn euch dieses video gefallen hat es
gibt uns einen daumen hoch
und wie immer sehen wir uns beim
nächsten mal
[Musik]